[Música]
volvió la electricidad a jerson en
Ucrania en medio de los
desabastecimientos de energía que padece
el país por los ataques rusos contra su
sistema eléctrico haremos un repaso de
qué está pasando
el ayatolá iraní Alí hija menei valoró
la represión que la milicia vasija ha
hecho las protestas al afirmar que los
uniformados han sacrificado sus vidas
esto a pesar de las denuncias que
señalan que en las manifestaciones han
muerto cerca de 500 personas
y Argentina sí que viva en el mundial de
fútbol de Qatar mientras que Francia se
convirtió en el primer equipo en
confirmar su paso a octavos de final las
dos elecciones ganaron frente a México y
Dinamarca respectivamente ampliamos
desde doha en minutos
Bienvenidos a las noticias
internacionales de Francia
Gracias por acompañarnos
este sábado la electricidad volvió a
gerson según dijo la presidencia
ucraniana y es que la luz la calefacción
y el agua estaban cortadas en la ciudad
desde que fue tomada por las fuerzas
ucranianas el 11 de noviembre la fecha
en la que la recuperaron de las tropas
rusas mientras que en toda Ucrania 6
millones de hogares incluidos 600.000 en
quienes la capital Siguen sin
electricidad Después de varios días de
ataques masivos por parte del ejército
de Moscú
una carrera contra el reloj mientras la
mitad de los habitantes todavía no
tienen electricidad el alcalde de la
ciudad acaba de expresar su gratitud a
los técnicos que restablecieron la
calefacción
quiero agradecerles a ustedes los 300
empleados de la compañía energética
templo de kiev ustedes quienes trabajan
día y noche gracias a ustedes podemos
anunciar hoy que el 97% de los hogares
tienen de nuevo calefacción las
temperaturas van bajando calor se vuelve
vital porque en Ucrania el invierno está
llegando y las temperaturas han pasado
bajo Cerro pero Rusia sigue bombardeando
las infraestructuras civiles esenciales
dejando millones de ucranianos o
electricidad desde kiefa al norte hasta
urdizal Sur desde las orillas del Dipper
al este hasta el VIP cerca de Polonia
hago un llamamiento a todos por favor
hagan reservas de agua carguen sus
celulares piensen en las comunicaciones
Prepárense con sus familias en caso de
que caigan las conexiones
Esta es una foto del cielo ucraniano
tomada a principios de febrero por la
NASA y otra tomada este jueves
secundaciones unidas la falta de energía
en Ucrania este invierno podría llevar a
nuevos desplazamientos de la población
dentro de los cuales podría haber un
Éxodo afuera del país
y en Italia las Fuertes lluvias
provocaron deslizamientos de tierra en
la isla de isquia en el suroeste del
país por lo menos 10 edificios
colapsaron y 12 personas estaban
desaparecidas Hasta ahora se ha
confirmado un muerto según la prefectura
de Nápoles a la que pertenece esta Isla
bomberos y guardias costeros Siguen
trabajando en las labores de rescate
le rindió un homenaje a la milicia basic
que ha reprimido las protestas que
llevan más de dos meses el líder supremo
dijo que ellos habían sacrificado sus
vidas a pesar que los activistas iraníes
han denunciado la muerte de 448 personas
en las manifestaciones mientras que un
equipo de médicos reportó que al menos
140 iraníes perdieron sus ojos por el
uso del armamento de las fuerzas de
seguridad la historia la tiene Gabriel
colchén
la represión se generan mientras las
manifestaciones entran en su tercer mes
en la provincia sudoriental de si están
balucci están las fuerzas de seguridad
abrieron Fuego contra los manifestantes
el viernes según los activistas decenas
de personas murieron o fueron heridas
tras la jornada de protestas las
manifestaciones fueron convocadas en
todo el país esta semana en Solidaridad
con el kurdistán que junto con el System
baluchistán ha sufrido particularmente
de la mortífera respuesta de las fuerzas
de seguridad el sábado el líder supremo
de Irán aléjame saludó el trabajo de los
basics una milicia islámica que ha
tomado parte en la represión del
movimiento vieron en estos asuntos
recientes que el pueblo perseguido de
basic se sacrificó para evitar que la
nación sucumbiera a la fuerza de un
grupo de asesinos Rebeldes analfabetos
esclavos se sacrificaron para evitar la
crueldad de otros según la agencia de
noticias de activistas de Derechos
Humanos
448 personas fallecieron desde el inicio
de las protestas que fueron convocadas
tras la muerte de masa a mini las
autoridades iraníes por su parte afirman
que unos 50 efectivos de las fuerzas de
seguridad murieron en las movilizaciones
este jueves el consejo de derechos
humanos de la ONU voto por la creación
de una investigación independiente sobre
la represión de las protestas pero eran
condenó la medida y dijo que era inútil
y representaba una violación de la
soberanía nacional del país
[Aplausos]
y en la actualidad del mundial de fútbol
de Qatar hoy se disputaron los cuatro
partidos de los grupos c y d Francia
ganó y se convirtió en el primer equipo
en pasar a los octavos mientras que
Argentina sigue viva en la fase de
grupos luego de su Victoria ante México
Polonia y Australia fueron los otros
vencedores de hoy desde doha nuestra
enviada especial Natalia Ruiz giraldo
nos hace un repaso de la jornada
Argentina juega el fénix Polonia pinchó
La burbuja de Arabia Saudita y Francia
logró su revancha Esos son los tres
resultados importantes de esta jornada
con Argentina que se midió aquí en el
estadio del usail ante el actriz ganando
dos goles por Cero en un partido
bastante difícil con muchísimas
interrupciones hasta 16 faltas en tan
solo en la primera parte pero Argentina
que sale a flote gracias a dos
generalidades una de Leonel Messi y
luego la segunda de Enzo Fernández en
todo caso lo que ocurre con Argentina
que por ahora es segundo de grupo se va
a decir en el último partido en donde la
albiceleste se enfrentará a Polonia
Polonia que a su vez ganó hoy a Arabia
Saudita dos goles por cero los saudíes
que se tuvieron que enfrentar ante el
muro de El Arquero polacochesni y dos
goles uno de celenski y el segundo de
lewandowski el 9 que por fin logra
marcar en orden mundial por el lado de
por fin ganaron a Dinamarca dos goles
por uno doblete de mbappé e los dos
hombres que hicieron los pases para
estos goles el primero Esteban Hernández
y el segundo es griezmann y con este
resultado de dos goles por uno pues ya
Francia tiene seis puntos y es la
primera selección aquí en Qatar 2022 en
estar en octavos de final
reapareció el ex presidente pakistaní
inrakan por primera vez desde que le
dispararon hace tres semanas y lo hizo
con un mensaje que profundiza la
división política dijo que su partido
Derek in saf abandonará todas las
asambleas regionales este colectivo
opositor fue el más votado y ya había
dejado la legislatura lo que dejó en un
limbo las elecciones parlamentarias del
jefe de estado
inrancan también reiteró su exigencia de
hacer votaciones anticipadas bajo el
argumento de que él fue derrocado
ilegalmente pero el Primer Ministro
chabás shariff con la ayuda del gobierno
estadounidense desestiman las
acusaciones y se mantienen en convocar
las elecciones para el 2023
la presidenta de Taiwán side in When
renunció como líder del gobernante
partido progresista democrático tras la
derrota de su formación en las
elecciones locales de este sábado la
oposición el partido nacionalista del
woming Tang el fundador de la llamada
República de China o Taiwán ganó en
varios territorios de la isla en la
votación en que se decidieron también
alcaldes concejales y otros líderes
locales tengo que asumir todas las
responsabilidades a partir de este
momento renuncio a la presidencia del
partido demócrata progresista Aunque el
gobierno central ha sido muy diligente
pero frente a este tipo de resultado hay
muchas cosas en las que tenemos que
pensar profundamente no pudimos romper
con la composición actual de la política
local esto demuestra que tenemos mucho
camino por recorrer cuando se trata de
administrar municipios y responder a las
expectativas de la gente previamente
hablamos con el politólogo Fernando
Pedrosa quien analizó diferencias entre
la línea ideológica del cuoming Tang
respecto al partido democrático y las
consecuencias de estas elecciones para
la política interna de Taiwán Hola Rosa
Qué tal efectivamente la posición tuvo
un fuerte triunfo en las elecciones
locales podemos decir que el Comitán el
partido histórico defiende una relación
madura con china una relación sin
conflicto no es un partido que defienda
una Unión con china volver a China
comunista pero sí una una política no
independentista y no de provocar al
gobierno comunista chino Bueno ahí sí
tiene más que hablar porque
efectivamente hay elecciones
presidenciales en 2024 isaí no puede
reelegir Entonces esto también si bien
no se puede pronosticar porque
efectivamente en 2018 ganaron comité y
en 2020 ganó 6 pero yo diría que estos
puede afectar en la sucesión porque el
candidato que perdió un typedia de
ministro de salud de SAE una persona
bastante reconocida por su significa en
la pandemia y fue Derrotado no en la
elección municipal O sea que nos puede
dejar algunas pistas para ver cómo se
organizan los partidos con vistas al
futuro de la lección presidencial hay un
nuevo récord de contagios de Kobe 19 en
China al confirmarse casi 40.000 nuevos
casos hoy es decir casi 5000 más que en
la víspera es el cuarto día en el que se
superan los registros anteriores Y a
medida que crece el brote aumenta
también el descontento público contra
las restricciones de la política cero
covid sobre todo en lugares como Beijing
y shinya
la paciencia se acaba en los vecindarios
de Beijing ante las severas
restricciones del gobierno chino
ciudadanos se enfrentan con los comités
de salud y también con la policía
restringieron nuestro edificio hace tres
días y en medio de la noche usaron esta
barra de madera para cerrar la entrada
escribiendo en ella fuera de servicio y
según los informes había personas en la
puerta impidiendo que los residentes
salieran esta mañana Cuando bajé vi esta
barra de madera y la quité porque creo
que es una cuestión de seguridad y ellos
no tienen derecho a sellar la puerta
protestas que no se limitan solo a
Beijing también en urunki y la capital
de yin yang donde el jueves 10 personas
murieron en un incendio presuntamente
por no haber podido escapar por los
cierres que viven y las complicaciones
que tuvieron los servicios de emergencia
para llevar a cabo los operativos de
rescate algo que las autoridades locales
no reconocen esto desencadenado la ira
en la región de mayoría huigur es decir
musulmana y contra la que las
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
denuncian que se cometen graves abusos
por el gobierno chino mientras que en
yum yo donde está la mayor fábrica de
iPhone del mundo también protestan
contra laborales y salariales en medio
del estricto encierro el gobierno de
chilling Ping defiende la política de
cero covid para evitar colapsar el
sistema de salud cuando un tercio de las
ciudades del país se encuentra bajo
confinamiento y en medio de todo la
economía se resiente
de
nkamón el 4 de noviembre de 1922 El
británico Howard Carter descubrió la
pista que guiaba a la tumba pero solo
fue hasta el 26 de noviembre que pudo
entrar por primera vez en el siguiente
informe conoceremos más de La ambiciosa
Búsqueda del arqueólogo
es la tumba de un faraón más conservada
que se haya encontrado y continúa siendo
una de las atracciones más populares en
el mundo en el corazón del Valle de Los
Reyes La tumba de Tutankamón ha
fascinado a Los visitantes por un siglo
excavadores encabezados por el
arqueólogo inglés Howard Carter la
descubrieron en noviembre de 1922
revelando primero unos escalones luego
una puerta un antesala y después de más
de un año de escarbar llegaron a un
segundo nivel que los condujo a una
tumba
se pueden imaginar la sorpresa cuando
deslizaron una lámpara en el hoyo y en
su luz parpadeante pudieron distinguir
una habitación llena de objetos uno más
hermoso que el otro todo en un desorden
cerca de 5.500 piezas invaluables se
apilaron en torno al sarcófago del joven
faraón más de 30 siglos atrás para
acompañarlo después de la muerte
Los arqueólogos quedaron cautivados por
la máscara de oro de 10 kilos El faraón
para desgracia de la momia
asombrado por la belleza de la máscara
Howard Carter se esperó en quitarse la
de encima a la momia y en el proceso
destruyó su cráneo
pocos meses después el descubrimiento el
financista de las excavaciones de cárter
murió en El Cairo le siguió la muerte de
un hombre de negocios que había visitado
la tumba y de un radiólogo que había
examinado la momia las noticias
alimentaron la Superstición de que
Tutankamón se estaba vengando de los que
perturbaron el lugar de su entierro la
maldición de los faraones Cien años
después su rostro sigue siendo el más
emblemático del Antiguo Egipto pero los
arqueólogos aún esperan encontrar a
Ramsés octavo el único faraón de la
vigésima dinastía cuya tumba no ha sido
identificada
el sueño de todo arqueólogo descubrir
más tesoros ocultos tan preciosos como
los de Tutankamón
murió Irene cara la actriz y cantautora
conocida por las películas flame y
Flashdance su publicista explicó a
través de un comunicado en Twitter que
se desconoce la causa de la muerte
escuchemos la canción del drama musical
que le valió un premio Óscar a la mejor
canción original y dos nominaciones a
los Grammy
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con France
[Música]